قررنا ان ندعم السيد رئيس الجمهوريه
السيد رجب طيب اردوغان رئيس التحالف
الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم المرشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه سابقا سنان اوغان يعلن دعمه
للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه
من الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقرره في 28 من
الشهر الجاري ويقول ان المعارضه لم تستطيع
اقنعهم في الجوله الاولى ولم تتمكن من
الحصول على اغلبيه البرلمان واشنطن تصف
اقتحام بنكفير للاقصى بالاسترجازي وتندد
بخطابه التحريضي وتنتقد الاستيطان في
الضفه الغربيه وتقول انه عقب اما محل
دولتين وقوه الاحتلال تقتل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين الشرقيه نابلس وتعتقل 13 في
عمليات دهم بالضفه
كيف تقول ان قوتها تواصل التقدم في محيط
باخموت مدينه بلكرود الروسيه تتعرض لقصف
اوكراني وموسكت تؤكد انها لن تسمح بتنفيذ
التهديدات بضرب القرد بسلاح امريكي بعد
تعرضه لاساءات من المدرجات خلال مباراه
الملك امام فالنسيا اللاعب البرازيلي
لريال مدريد فينيسيوس جونيور يتهم رابطه
الدوريه الاسباني لكره القدم بالعنصريه
ونيابه العامه في فالنسيا تفتح تحقيقا في
الحادثه في حين اعلن الرئيس البرازيلي عن
دعمه للاعب وطلب بمنع الفاشيه من التوغل
في الملاعب على حد وصفه الى اللقاء